ce qui est sûr c'est que jusqu'à présent
on était les sols objets intelligents
dans l'univers on avait le monopole de
l'intelligence tout d'un coup on voit
arriver une deuxième espèce intelligente
qui est l'intelligence artificielle et
qui est manifestement probablement en
train de nous dépasser en capacité
intellectuelle et donc cette révolution
là elle a des conséquences politiques
éducatives il faut bien évidemment ce
que l'école forme nos gamins au métier
de l'air de chaque GPT et pas à l'heure
d'avant chaque GPT donc le ministre de
l'éducation doit présenter un plan
d'adaptation de l'école pour que nos
gamins soient compétitifs à l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle et puis il
faut aussi que collectivement nous ayons
un débat national et dans chaque pays un
débat politique pour savoir ce que l'on
fait de cette intelligence artificielle
qui n'a pas que de mauvais côté en
médecine en cancérologie on va faire des
progrès absolument inouïe vous avez
probablement vu alors c'est pas une puce
d'Elon musk mais vous avez probablement
vu la semaine dernière grâce à de
artificielle et des implants dans le
cerveau et dans la moelle on arrive à
faire remarcher des paralysés c'est un
truc extraordinaire on ne peut pas
considérer que l'intelligence
artificielle n'est porteuse que de
risques elle est aussi porteuse d'une
révolution médicale qui va tous nous
apporter des choses extraordinaires le
progrès scientifique c'est bien quand ça
favorise l'humain quand c'est au service
de l'humain là on a l'impression qu'on
veut desservir l'humain et faire
disparaître complètement les les hommes
et les femmes et les remplacer à leur
travail et Gilles tout à l'heure parler
de 80% des emplois est-ce qu'on
s'enflamme pas un peu trop par exemple
quand tu fais remarcher un paraplégique
non mais c'est l'humain mais d'accord
mais justement comment on fait TPMP avec
chat GPT comment on fait tourner un
restaurant et chat j'ai pété par exemple
alors la réponse à cette question les
les créateurs de chaque GPT sont en
train de créer une gamme de robots les
robots néo donc tu vas avoir des robots
avec l'intelligence d'Aristote dans
quelques années donc on va pouvoir faire
tourner la cuisine d'aristorant avec des
robots de paix à l'intelligence
artificielle il faut pas penser que la
révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle ne concerne que appelle les
colles blancs que les métiers non
manuels les métiers manuels vont aussi
être impactés parce qu'on voit on va
voir apparaître des des robots dotés de
l'intelligence artificielle donc la
gamme de robot Neo va incorporer chaque
GPT version 4 donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse pour tous les métiers et le
but c'est pas uniquement pour les
métiers non manuel que tout le monde
soit au chômage n'est plus de travail
mais non plein de nouveaux métiers vont
apparaître dans la création dans
l'innovation dans l'art dans la médecine
dans la cancérologie on va inventer
plein de nouveaux métiers grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle le seul
problème c'est qu'il faut pas qu'il y
ait des laisser de côté il faut que il
faut que l'école arrête de glander il
faut que l'école forme nos enfants à
cette révolution mais il y a pas que
l'école il faut que nous aussi on
apprenne à nos enfants à se servir
moi je passe avec mes enfants énormément
de temps pour qu'ils se servent bien de
gpt4 de la version 4 de chaque GPT il
s'en sert très bien ils savent comment
poser les questions ils savent comment
travailler mieux plus intelligent non
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle
chaque parent chacun d'entre nous doit
faire la même chose il faut que vous
accompagnons nos enfants dans cette
révolution
grève parce que justement les scénarios
sont écrits par jade député alors
comment on va faire en fait parce que
vous dites que ça crée de l'intelligence
mais ça crée aussi donc de la du chômage
comment on doit se réinventer quand on
est scénariste quand on est voilà quand
on est écrivain comment doit se
réinventer s'il y a déjà été pété qui va
prendre notre temps quand l'automobile
est arrivé on a bien vu la disparition
d'une partie importante des
maréchaufferrants parce qu'il y avait
moins de chevaux mais l'industrie
automobile a créé beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'emplois des centaines de millions
d'emplois sur Terre les garagistes les
gens qui fabriquent des autoroutes etc
beaucoup plus d'emplois que ceux qui ont
été détruits par la disparition d'une
bonne partie des marées chauffeurs ça va
être la même chose il y a plein de
métiers qui vont disparaître plein de
métiers vont arriver je te rappelle
qu'en 1793
à la à la grande période de Robespierre
il y avait 29000 porteurs d'eau à Paris
avec l'eau courante qui est arrivé en
1840 à Paris il y a plus de porteurs
d'eau en revanche il y a plus de 29000
personnes aujourd'hui qui s'occupent de
diffuser
de nettoyer l'eau de vérifier la qualité
de l'eau donc il y a plus de porteur
d'eau mais les gens qui gèrent l'eau à
Paris ils sont plus nombreux aujourd'hui
que les porteurs d'eau en 1793